What's up Buzzer Welcome back to another Episode of Safe pack the Fractured but
Whole Let's Continue Playing everybody let's go
Oh, oh, the support Just Rip Into Nintendo
Someone Get Polygon this is  Outrageous
Real The fuck you're Singing mean, ah he Can, Pass me Anyway, oh?
Excuse me I was actually a, miss click a miss fart
Where is scrambles we're Real Close I can Feel it?
I
Know who is that
Well i should be Easy he has A drum that was A drone Controller
It's not a drunk
Disappointed Alright, We're Gonna Defeat general Disarray that Should, be Easy let's do This
How much Lego Can you have Dude like that's A lot, of lego let's get Really
Alright - in With the Cure Gain
The Dialogue Is so buggy like it clearly Said Get Queuing There but it Actually Say
Oh, yeah, he has A weird one That goes like Diagonally and See if We can hit more Than?
No okay, well I guess this is the attack, we're doing now?
So this will Probably, do do more damage right because It'll push him Back to Cartman Card enabled Pushing back Nice
They Have Mecha Minions Great
Yes, oh, wow
Is he Standing in the Lava
Vamonos Mecha Minion
Wow they got the Technology straight from Japan?
Who Would at that okay yeah Old?
Bring it Mr.
Hayes Almost Then
my God How, Many Minutes Does he Have my god Mexicans Everywhere
He might be able to finish him, yeah that one Does A lot of damage that
Was that We just Had to Take out the general, okay Nice?
That's what I always Say ignore the Mexicans and Take out the general
Hey we've got an Epic sign yeah man that is Great I feel Really good about This one, oh?
Wow oh no this Is love everywhere now
no, no
No I'm Already dead, okay
We're Gonna find a way to save you do something to it yet There's Nothing here my sand blaster Needs Compressed Hair to Work it's
The One From the Entrance the gates Landing Lunch not Remember it's okay, Guys
We all Knew when we signed on to be Coon Friends that it might end like this stay Calm super craig
We're Gonna get you home sorry Dude but it looks like this was a one-Way trip, no?
I'm starting With everett things like that
We found a match?
What are you doing
Are you Crazy do you know what Kind of Firepower someone Would need to Make that Work, ah don't underestimate my Power
Don't underestimate a man
that's is A
Super Craig I had to Stabilize you are you serious right now
Kill me Look fuck did You get that Carmen
Online super craig Just Stay Still you suffered a lot you Guys go ahead I'm Gonna Just Try and Stabilize him
Really cool Back There Now, We Can Clear love it Whenever we want?
We make a great Team but Lord?
All right so we Unlocked and you Bought a buddy Power by the power of Shoving Tubes in our?
Butt
Bit okay all right I guess I'll go here There's Probably will be something up, no Never mind. I can't Walk
I'm so sick of the Lava I
I agree 100%
We Can Break this Maybe?
You're Liable for Any Property Damage all right, We can use our Body Power and A wine When he'll read Kyle When Clearly
This One's Easy, They Sure Love fart Jokes in the sun but They Sure, do
Well We have This over here right but then what I have to be Up there it's to jump Down isn't it
Have i lost all Hub, well We have one More?
You Just Dying
How, oh
yes of Course
Ha ha, ok, all right ok, ok, I read again yeah yeah all right Let's Take off Buddy
Hardcore miss Tan
Someone Told me also that you Make more Money, oh my god it's so beautiful if you're White in the game I
Don't know if That's True
All Right I guess you left us huh
We got a pack of Ramen which you can't See Because I'm Covering this Screen with my beautiful Face
Where to now Actually There's some more Stuff Behind here why not, why not, We got some Bg?
Balls Whatever that Is and Some more China plates great?
Love our Outfit Though love love love it looks like, we're Gonna have to use Says, sam's Power here
Yeah, no I know and he's got A fart on it
You Gotta Fought on the Lava thank you
Nice One all right Let's Keep Going but lord it's a really good game Mechanic that I really, Enjoy him
Edgar Salute Edgar what the heck man I
Need to stop Calling out Stuff that you guys Clearly can't even See, but you know
You got to Keep Loading me
Should We Attack These Guys Are Sneaky i ran I?
Feel like, we're Gonna have to fight him right
Now okay, We can Just I can hear Cats They must be Any?
Final, oh
That's Some Real High-grade Shit There Cat. Like that Would go to the boss man Himself you idiots you, don't Talk about him now
We gotta Kill These Shits?
Okay, i'm down to kill them so
There was One Episode I remember the Long Ago Where
People Would Take the Cat Urine and to get higher or Whatever I don't know what to do with the kun kun Is so useless
so
Stop Here
Somebody's About to get Fixed who's it gonna be This one might do it no
All right hit him, oh Shit the Barrels Gonna Explode, ah Damn it's Gonna Explode on us Though
Shoes ok, well at least Now We know
Maybe, We can use the laser here yeah let's do it perfect?
It's gonna blow Look at that
They Can Heal Because They have Drugs
Hey, oh, oh, wow not really, we're Actually you're Doing pretty, well that ok?
We have A combat Buddy what Is that ok all right What Can Call Girls do then huh blow up Individual
That's Pretty Good
Are you texting the Barrel
Nice oh Another one They're all gonna blow it's a chain Effect
Nice very Nice
And here We go nailed it
What is in The back With the cans man Jesus?
All Right that's not very Christian man I don't know what to tell you
We just put the Cat Urine in The drug the hem Yeah?
It's like it's like he, Wants more Crime in the Streets Professor ko, no no way no Spooky man
We got to do This if They tell Us don't you get it
What a way to go not a bad way to go
Nice and here, We go, okay?
I'm Ready or do We have to use her the Password Is 0 1 2 3
uncrackable uncrackable Code Luckily, I'm a crack Master i mean I
Guess I didn't do it right
okay, Let's Try, using the Butthole in The Thing
They're Happy About that okay alright that's Interesting you're Not A Bad to beat so happy
Got'em Combat Advantage Baby Look at that Shit
No other Youtuber Could do that that Takes Skill Takes Years of Crayon my god that was beautiful
Garrett Gayo Gayo Rat okay you Come in Here Voice
Go Tell Everyone you cut Yourself Manscaping
And it's cute Tan
Hell yes I mean God church yes We?
Did it
I'm glad that thing broke I, was like Should I shoot her Or not?
But where Is he?
He got, away, we Gotta use?
Flip
What is that?
Anyway We Gotta Use said the Butthole Thing, oh?
my God if Someone
Alright Put That One There and then when This was a little Trickier?
Hell yes indeed Stain Let's go my face is Literally Inside his Butt, oh?
Wow they got A?
Yes Seriously That's A lot of love a man
Why do I say lava it's lego it's lenka, oh
my God
What is oh what?
You Mean Mecha Mexican Minion Care to play
okay, let's do This one We got a pretty Strong lineup so I
Like how One Guy Is just Literally his Crotch Look at the Guy in the Crotch, oh
My God okay, We got it move up, oh, wow, his shootings from There huh
Well you know that's a microaggression They're Saying extra Spicy Just Because you're Mexican Fuck I'm Burning?
We're Just Gonna use These I made a ton of them Anyway
Congratulations, oh you, had to do how do I shoot him that hits him, okay?
on ice
Should Probably like Split Up, oh
That was nice all those Fireworks
No, no, no, no, no no not sam Damn it
What in That what?
I'm Burning now
Damn it ah, Cuz, you're Just Walking across Whatever Just Take it
Get Caned okay I know it's gonna be a second you know it's gonna be
What Is he Saying Get the shit med by?
Yeah Phase Two
Let's go, oh!
They're Gonna Heal Them, we're Gonna have to take out the yeah they're Gonna here like dammit
I could Just use the Old and kill all of them let's do it it's the quickest Way
But we're Gonna have to?
Know I'm Actually Impressed I totally Smell like A
King Wait, We Can't Actually Attack There what how do I attack him then?
There's No, no, no, no, no no no no you bet no
Finish him Finish him
Thank you no Whaling on my Watch
So dog in There, oh my god that's Another Face There's a third Face Everyone
Shut Up I
Think we Can Finish him?
I'm done Done Easy miss demon what up
Look at that xp. Look at it go up just like my DinG-A-Ling very Nice very Nice
Yeah Money, well spent but?
It was great Working With you again man?
Yeah, well i told you this was A one-Shot Deal?
Come on Shed Come Back to the
Can't do That Kite Freedom Pals is gonna Make Way more Money with Their Franchise you're Wrong, we're Gonna Make like a billion Dollars
We're Gonna Make like a Billion
We're Back at Headquarters
Who could it Be Maybe it's that Tommy Nothing Kid he's always Been Kind of A dick Have A seat Thundercats
Are you just at this. Is that A key Cartridge that's Kind of cool
It doesn't cost
Much a recipes
okay
Why not
No I'm not Gonna Join them
Yeah That's Pretty cool, why not, why not?
oh
My God Could it be no it's impossible No it is Possible
There's Only One Person I know of who Can Disguise Himself so Easily
And it's the Same Person who might have a motive for Tearing south Park apart, oh
Mitch Conner What Wait, sorry
When his Cover was Blown he was Arrested by the police but escaped but?
Why Would he want to Take Down that pie and Where Would he get all his Money
Shut Up it's not Registered With Fucking Connor
I'll be you know know Kylie's Right you Guys it Couldn't be Mitch Connor Connor died in an oil Rig Explosion in Northern Alaska
Fuck This I'm going to bed
Yes yes Good Idea hear me cut. Everyone get Back to your Homes it's getting late Let's all reconvene Tomorrow After
And Now the News Program that Starts your, day off right good Morning South Park
The South Park
Vigilante Struck again Last Night this Time at a meth lab in The downtown new Storage
Facility Here With more Is a midget in A fedora table six
men Were Arrested last Night after the vigilante Exposed A Huge meth lab in The Storage Facility Behind me
Eyewitnesses Have Come Forward With Shocking Reports That The vigilantes Parts
Were so awful they Seemed to actually Rip the Fabric of Time you ain't never heard A fart like this man he
Was like One Minute he Farted on my dick you're the next Thing my dick
Was like 20 Seconds in The Path Whoa?
Finally Someone is Standing up to all the Crime in this city if you ask me These People here all Deserve to be Farted on
He's a menace if You asked me How Long before This vigilante Gets Radical and Blows Up a school or a church huh
How Long before Captain America Becomes Captain ideology
The Third Captain America Movie
How long was that?
About Six Years About six Years
Dozens of Protesters Gathered Outside The Police Station Today as A warrant was issued for the vigilantes Arrest
Crusaders and Sneak Around and fart on People at night
We urge all citizens to arm Themselves and Fight against this kind of rectal the pressure?
Rectal Oppression I've Never Thought I heard Those Words
Yeah it's me Nobody Knows Anything about this Kid not what Race it is again
If it's a boy or a girl what
Do We do so are They Talking about a house Just Keep getting the Product
Into People's DruGs and Alcohol I'll Handle the vigilantes are You Seri Thing out of Control
You Said you Could get the Mayor out of Office you wanted to be Left alone Commissioner
Doing I'Ve Made that happen Just stay Calm and soon Everyone will Have Exactly what they Read
That's sewed up yes
My Name is Wendy nice to have you at our school hmm that little Girl told you
About it's A lot Worse the chamber of Commerce wants to get Rid of the vigilant
Oh, no, Matter what it Takes you know the Bathrooms in The Park Paul girl, wants you to meet her There right now
okay
Let me Just Read Transform here wow that was so cool, wasn't he?
Stop don't Judge Me, don't Judge me Just Butter out a Different Clothes Came on?
That it shut Up i look cool a gala cool, get Real I look cool
Alright well Let's Tell it Transport it's now five to nine the Password
Can you be at two places at Once
Right
Need to get Somewhere
Soda Sob that's at the end of the Shoes we're Gonna have to walk I?
Love that Episode so Funny Anyway Alyssa's Walk There this is it yeah yeah this is it
Where We see Though meet Me and They start Soda Sopa in The Space Formerly Occupied by Steed?
We Needs an Incense?
I'm Buddies Still Have Willing to help at least I mean he doesn't want to Shove Up a long in someone's dong you know
We did indeed Goodbye
Legend all right This is Kenny's House that's not it
Hey They got it in Brighton, oh?
There's The Steed I saw it now
Okay, this is it I guess, we're Meeting the king Paine Looking for answers yes
Mr.. Connor sends his Regards he Wanted to come Himself But he's A very busy, man
He Mentioned some Horrible Tragedy Happened to your Mother
Funny How A few Moments in our lives Can Completely Change who
We are and now you're gonna Be Taken out by assassins Known as the city Ninja service it was a drag
of Course
The City Ninjas you
Know what to do with them when, you're Done
After it's done
You'll Pay your Badge back Up that's on the Website you don't sound Japanese you sure you're Really Ninjas
Just get it over With Shitting in Your Service
You want to?
I don't have Five Thousand
In Business Money for Bribes so We Still have to murder you, sorry
Okay all right, oh they, join, me Even What the heck
All right, well I guess, We have to kill them?
Minja Stop so what They're korean?
What Should We Attack win Coon is Actually Getting Better he's not that Bad?
Wait They're Korean what the Heck Definitely got That Wrong?
Finish him Nice
No more what the heck. I wasn't Ready for that all right Whatever?
What does more are you Kidding me okay one of them is Down?
Yes yes Nice The white ninjas are Dead
Yes we're On A roll come on Baby?
Yeah he's dead
it'S fine
Seriously Now Super Craig I doubt it okay here, we go?
Wait I'Ve Never Seen super craig's yes, oh my God
That's my new Favorite what I can't let's finish this, oh?
And There it Is that was Hard that, was Really difficult yeah Damn Boring
Stupid Idiot Shitty Aeneas
Alright what do We get I
Guess so and now, we're Alone again that doesn't Really Make any sense for the plot I thought this, would be a solo fight
Member
By Member of
Isis
I get down from here a Matter of days okay?
No how'd I even Get up here oh I know from here what, oh?
Alright Now, We go back to Coons lair
Okay, hello Kid Known as Butthole You got lucky one Time but CD She Didn't heed me A lurking Shadow, no no, oh man
Okay all right okay, we're Gonna Have to Watch out for them now?
Goddamn Shitty Ninjas
Let's go to the Kuhn layer and pretend Nothing Happened Nothing at out Nothin Eddo
No Girls allowed, okay?
okay
will do
After I end This Episode
Thank You Guys so much for Watching Another one Really loved it Recording These all the support as
Always I know I keep Saying it but Appreciate you guys Squad for him